[Music]
Maya's mental health awareness month and
this morning we're beginning our
Wellness week series we're going to have
a wellness week series guys with
conversations dedicated to the
importance of mental health and wellness
nearly 58 million Americans did you hear
that number live with a mental illness
research shows rates of anxiety and
depression are increasing we are joined
Now by a panel of leading experts
board-certified psychiatrist that's Dr
Sue Varma you've seen her here as a
clinical assistant and professor of
Psychiatry at NYU clinical psychologist
Tamer Bryant is a 2023 president of the
American Psychological Association thank
you very much she's also also the author
of homecoming overcoming fear and Trauma
to reclaim your whole authentic self and
last but certainly not least clinical
psychologist at Lisa demore is also also
with us if you've watched a show on a
regular basis hope you do you've seen
Lisa here many times her latest book by
the way is the emotional lives of
teenagers raising connected capable and
compassionate adolescents it's true Lisa
that can be done good morning to you all
good morning
um so I want to start with you about the
numbers of mental health I went for a
walk yesterday in Central Park and saw a
couple people who were clearly having
some kind of episode one guy was just
screaming I love you then he went I hate
you then he went I want to kill you
clearly having an episode so that was an
extreme case but there are so many
people that are having mental health
episodes that we know nothing about is
this in fact a crisis that everybody
says it is an epidemic that everybody
says yes Gail and this existed even
before the pandemic I'd love to be able
to say that we always explain the
pandemic yes yes and even though we're
coming out of it and we have all sorts
of uncertainties whether it's economic
political racial climate change it
really does come down to the fact that
our stressors are many but our buffers
are few and our stressors are things
that we feel like we don't have agency
and control over and when we lose agency
we strip ourselves of our dignity and
mental health symptoms rise we're also
in a loneliness crisis so in my mind as
mental health symptoms go up it's not
surprising that 50 or more people are
feeling lonely in America Dr Murthy just
called it the other day an epidemic
absolutely yes and loneliness um as the
surgeon general's advisory said
increases our rates of depression uh
double doubles it so we're looking at
the fact that we have less social Civic
engagement less of these so sort of soft
tissue connections if you will and more
of the uncertainty and less agency
another big problem Dr Bryant is trauma
people are experiencing trauma what's
your advice on how to get through that
what to do with that yes it's so
important to know that we are more than
what has been done to us and so we
really encourage people to shift from
shame and self-blame to self-compassion
and our science really promotes the use
of both self-care and Community Care so
that self-care is taking care of our
bodies taking care of our mental health
through therapy and also exercising our
boundaries and knowing that we can be
intentional about who we connect with
but knowing we also don't alone so it's
hard not to blame yourself it really is
because we get messages from society
that are victim blaming and so really
empowering people to resist that but
also equipping us to be supportive when
other people share their experiences of
trauma for us to respond with support
instead of change Lisa when we talk
about stressors and also the lack of
buffers I think of social media
particularly when it comes to kids
what's the effect of social media do we
know at this point on young people
well social media on its own is neither
good nor bad but there's certainly what
we can call problematic use so if it's
excessive or if it gets in the way of
things that are necessary for healthy
development or if kids are in toxic
online environments and actually Dr
Brian's APA just put out an
extraordinary advisory incredibly useful
for families about what healthy social
media use looks like and it really does
get at the fact that social media should
not keep kids from sleeping keep kids
from being Physically Active keep kids
from having one-on-one interpersonal
interactions with other people and we
also just want to be careful that
they're not in toxic environments that
promote self-harm or eating disorder
Behavior or hate or anything else that
we know is bad for kids you know Sue
speaking of self-harm we've seen suicide
rates going up in this country there
have been a lot of high profile suicides
recently and my question is can you when
you think about children and you look at
their lives is it possible to
early on see signs that may point to
Future mental health issues down the
line and if so what can parents do to
address them so it doesn't get to that
point yes and so we look at something
called adverse childhood events and
we're having more understanding of sort
of what we call the Social determinants
of mental illness and looking at the
environments whether it's anything from
incarceration domestic violence
untreated mental illness substance abuse
in the family history of trauma
intergenerational trauma all of this
predisposes children to stress and
specifically we look at the telomeres
when it comes to chromosomes these are
signs markers of aging and we see that
the pandemic for example and the social
isolation that children were
experiencing also promoted accelerated
aging in the brain and in the body so
being able to get help now that we have
screenings for anxiety and depression
that are now becoming commonplace in the
Pediatrics office pediatrician's office
integrating mental health into the fold
of primary care so that it is routine
that you ask these basic questions we
talked about social media use substance
abuse self-harm we also see that teen
Dating Violence is puts us at risk young
girls at risk for self-harm later on so
being able to catch these things early
and promoting healthy Behavior adults
have to model that in relationships
setting boundaries what is toxic what
what do we are we willing to accept and
also being able to say no and empowering
our children to say no to things that
make them feel uncomfortable Dr Brian
let's talk about people of color seeking
help I keep hearing that a people of
color don't seek help uh in in the
numbers that others do is it because we
don't want to or because it's not
available it is really both so there's
the reality of stigma around seeking
mental health of still a stigmas there
is still a stigma but I will say that
has decreased that more people are more
people of color are seeking services but
the other reality is we are
underrepresented in the field so if
people feel more comfortable talking to
someone of their same culture it's
harder to find that person and then lack
of access to mental health services so
the American Psychological Association
has both been working to advocate for
equity in terms of access to Quality
Mental Health Services but also looking
to diversify the field so we've been
dedicating funds to really looking at
how do we eradicate racism not only in
society but within the field so that
when you see someone they can be attuned
to your culture and recognize that
Injustice and oppression are sources of
stress you also guys have to get the
right therapist I went to a therapist
once and I'm pouring my heart out and I
hear
oh do you know how debilitating that is
yes I mean so it's I know that's what I
thought too about I gathered my things
and just sort of crept out of the door
it creates ruptures it does people see
someone who is not attentive or not
attuned you can believe that that's what
therapy is so we really try to encourage
people to shop around yeah don't be
turned off so if you have a bad
experience that's my point yes well as
therapists often say our time today is
done that that's our session thank you
both I've heard you know very much but
it's free
our time is up so Varma we thank you
team bright good to see you and Lisa de
Moore always good to see you if you or
someone you know is seeking Mental
Health Resources there are plenty of
things you can do first you can call the
National Alliance on Mental Illness
helpline that number is
1-800-950-62-64
1-800-950-6264 we'll put it on our
website or you can text helpline to